vincent avait bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le gérant de ce garage moto à
pont-sur-yonne c'est bien ça le 1er
octobre vous avez été victime d'une
tentative de cambriolage il est tout
autour de 22h45
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
j'ai entendu un bruit
j'étais en train de faire de papier un
bruit pas normal un bouleversant dans la
nuit qui est pas normal et j'ai pris mon
fauteuil roulant électrique je suis
descendu faire une ronde sur le sur le
parc et là je me suis bougé d'y lever
les mains arrêter tout face à vous il y
avait deux hommes
c'est là qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient chez
vous il était en train de démonter une
moto récupérer toutes les pièces cuisine
qui était dessus ce qu'il faut préciser
c'est qu'à ce moment là vous étiez armée
et vous avez tiré un moment donné oui
j'ai dû tirer j'ai tiré une première
fois en l'air pour pour faire une
sommation pour prévenir que je rigolais
pas donc ils se sont sauvés sont passés
par des feux l'union j'ai repris mon
fauteuil quand on est devenue enceinte
pour les retrouver à l'extérieur vous
les est sommé de s'arrêter et j'ai été
neutralisée durant un bon quart d'heure
le temps que la gendarmerie arrive la
remet en question vous l'avez apportées
pour nous souvenir que vous avez le
droit d'utiliser oui c'est une arme que
j'ai le droit d'utiliser c'est une arme
qui doit être utilisé dans l'enceinte
privé mais c'est quoi ce sont des balles
c'est quoi ce sont des balles en
caoutchouc
propulsé par de la poudre ça peut
blesser
ça peut immobiliser une personne à temps
par des douleurs et ses non létales vous
craignez pas que votre geste il incite
d'autres personnes à s'armer à leur tour
et à faire la même chose savaient si
aujourd'hui on arrive à neutraliser des
gens qui sont nuisibles et les remettent
à la justice si la justice d'ailleurs
fait son travail il y aura moins de
problèmes et il y aura moins d'intrusion
et et on réglera c'est pas à faire
justice soi même c'est parce que j'ai
fait ce que je veux c'est juste que on
respecte le travail des autres on
respecte une enceinte une une intimité
et que ça leur serve de leçon
qui recommence pas parce que il y aura
tout le temps des gens comme moi et il y
en aura malheureusement de plus en plus
parce que il ya des commerces qui seront
pires régulièrement mais les gens ils en
sont à un point où soit ils baissent les
bras ou soit jianfu mais effectivement
c'est pas à mettre dans toutes les mains
ce genre de choses merci beaucoup